here's what i love here's what i love
the best about it we knew we were coming
on the road against the hottest team in
football and i know everyone in this
locker room we expected to win this game
because we know that's the kind of team
we have that's what we've built that's
where we're going and we're just getting
started right we're just getting started
frank wright coach of the colts giving
his players credit after they ended the
houston texans nine game winning streak
the texans took the cheese bill o'brien
said don't take the cheese and then like
somebody asked him what does it mean to
take the cheese and he's he's like well
you know you got a mouse trap and
there's like a you know there's a spring
and right and if you take the cheese i
can't believe i'm explaining this is
what he said and yeah i didn't know
anybody out there didn't know that would
analogy
the colts took the cheese and ran with
it captain andrew luck very happy after
yesterday's out dude
and and you know look the texans oh my
goodness they'd be in such great shape
if they had won that game because the
patriots lost and and it could have come
down to the texans or the chiefs for the
one seed but i'm not going to give up on
the texans just because they finally
lost the game they weren't going to go
13-3 no although
the table was kind of set for
13 in them
they did but they met their kryptonite
you know we talk about the texans a lot
and we go desean watson of course and
then what's the next thing we think
about they're d-line right well the
colts had that great all-o line we saw
them protect and give them time to hit
passes down the field and then i do
worry about the texans offense a little
mike the the pass game when their run
game is not there i don't know if their
pass game is diverse enough to carry
them in games like we saw yesterday it's
just thing i'm saying
how different no points scored at
jacksonville and they beat the texans
the following week yeah
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports